[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre chers collègues la sécheresse
historique de cet été nous rappelle
combien la question de la gestion de la
ressource en eau est essentiel pour
notre pays à cet effet le Sénat rendra
cette semaine un rapport dans lequel
nous définissons des priorités pour
éviter d'être demain dans une situation
encore plus difficile que celle
d'aujourd'hui nous nous interrogeons
toutefois sur les motivations du
gouvernement à agir concrètement pour
être en phase avec les attentes des
territoires en matière de couvertance
tout d'abord le Sénat s'est prononcé sur
la nécessité de préserver la souplesse
d'un transfert facultatif de la
compétence en eau de la commune vers les
intercommunalités cela pour une raison
très simple l'eau répond à une logique
de bassin versant et non de périmètre
intercommunal il est également une autre
évidence se transfère rendu obligatoire
d'ici 2026 a et va générer une
augmentation significative du prix de
l'eau pour l'usager
s'agissant de la question des ressources
financières là encore vous vous
détournez de vos obligations lors du
débat sur le financement des agences de
l'eau au Sénat en janvier le
gouvernement avait pris l'engagement de
présenter les grands axes de leur futur
financement elles ont subi labaissement
de leur plafond de recettes en 2018 et
se voit ponctionner une part importante
de leur budget notamment par l'Office
français de la biodiversité de fait
comme cela avait déjà été exprimé nos
redoutons que contrairement aux
principes fondateurs l'eau ne paye plus
l'eau mais l'eau paye l'État comme
souvent vos choix ou plutôt vos absences
de décision mettent à mal nos
territoires ma question est donc simple
madame la Première ministre allez-vous
entendre la voix des territoires qui
demandent plus de liberté dans la
gouvernance de l'eau et plus de moyens
pour agir
[Applaudissements]